[Field recording: morning market sounds]
Narrator: Sound is memory before it becomes language.
For many in the African diaspora, the sounds of home carry a kind of grief that photographs cannot.
Kwame: The first thing I looked for when I moved to London was somewhere that sounded right.
Not looked right — sounded right. I found a market near Peckham. Fridays only.
Amara: You carry the hills with you.
That's what my grandmother told me. She meant the sound of wind across the hills.
Tolu: I never left, so for me it's the opposite.
I watch my cousins come back and I see them hear Lagos for the first time again.
Narrator: What unites all three voices is not nostalgia — it's attention.
[Closing field recording: evening prayer call fading into city ambience]